hey Conan 360 live I am John Kronus of
Warner Brothers Studio Tour Hollywood I
am currently standing in the Warner
Brothers archive Museum and I cannot
wait to show you around some of my
absolute favorite things let's check it
out here we have Wonder Woman now this
is as you would have seen her in Batman
vs Superman where we were really
introduced to gal gadot performance of
Wonder Woman and we have her original
costume here absolutely love it if you
guys check it out they were designed by
Michael Wilkinson directed by Zack
Snyder what a wonderful wonderful movie
great character great performance right
next to that just in case you know we
ever have another super attack we have
the Kryptonite staff that Batman uses
also in Batman vs Superman speaking of
Batman take a look now he's got a few
different costumes that we actually see
in Batman vs Superman and this is one of
my personal favorite ones you can see
that it's really got some wear and tear
because he is Batman he's been Batman
for a really long time
how cool are these things now we're back
in the Suicide Squad section of our
archive and you can see some of the
Joker's henchmen I actually tried to
borrow this for Valentine's Day not only
did the studio not let me do it but my
girlfriend was like absolutely not we
have another one of the Joker's henchmen
he's got an eye for crime moving right
along you can see the Joker himself
right here played by Jared Leto and his
Joker was really kind of inspired by
like the rich kids of Instagram is a
very indulgent Joker and believe it or
not how many people know this this is
the exact tuxedo Jared Leto also wore to
the Academy Awards all authentic
costumes and props all the way on the
wall over here we have part of the Wayne
mausoleum and also little Wayne right
here we also have one of my favorite
things all original first edition number
one comics straight out of the DC comic
vault never been on display before we
have Green Lantern we have flash the
very first Batman comic we have Superman
we have Wonder Woman we have cyborg come
on guys cyborg get excited New Teen
Titans that's what that is we also have
Aquaman we have the Lois Clark and Perry
suits from The Daily Planet and as you
can clearly see Superman himself 3d
printed suit you have to put this thing
on like a wet suit
he's also got the language of Krypton
across the essent on his shoulders and a
little known fact they actually got the
molding from tour guides for the suit
right here that's not true at all
listen that's gonna do it for me John
Kronus come see all of these things for
yourself at Warner Brothers Studio Tour
Hollywood because these are just a few
of the amazing things on this tour so
book your tickets today WB studio tour
calm and we will see you soon